que un nouvel invité jean de gliniasty
ancien ambassadeur de france en russie
et directeur de recherche à l'institut
de relations internationales et
stratégiques hauteur de petite histoire
des relations franco russes aux éditions
de l'inventaire
bonjour jean de gliniasty merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
gelé bien vous avez été ambassadeur de
france à moscou
gardez vous des souvenirs un particulier
du défilé du 9 mai auquel vous avez
assisté quand vous étiez à moscou
bonjour oui en effet j'ai assisté à cinq
du filet et à chaque fois c'est une
énorme fête
simplement j'ai noté il y a une espèce
de de baromètre de la situation
internationale dans ce dans ce défilé
quand il ya beaucoup d'invités étrangers
au plus haut niveau ça veut dire que les
relations sont bonnes quand il y en a
peu ça veut dire que les relations sont
mauvaises et on voit qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
période de tension vous le disiez un peu
de chefs d'état étrangers ont assisté à
ce défilé simplement des ambassadeurs
l'ambassadeur américain et
un membre de l'ambassade britannique
également justement les relations russe
avec les pays extérieurs on sait ce
second un peu compliqué en ce moment en
tout cas avec le monde occidental
c'est sûr que là la clusaz hic la crise
ukrainienne a été un secteur 2 de
tension dans les relations entre la
russie et le monde occidental
on a vu récemment bien sûr d'aider des
expulsions d'ambassadeurs de part et
d'autre un de de la russie est ce que
cette tension diplomatique a pu avoir un
poids sur cette journée du 9 mai au je
crois que c'est un ensemble
les expulsions de diplomates c'est un
peu comme des rageux un signe mais c'est
un signe de deux de tension globale et
c'est sûr que ça jouait un rôle bien
entendu mais il ya beaucoup d'éléments
qui constitue en fait les les facteurs
de tensions actuellement on a vu on va
retenir va revenir bien entendu sur
cette cérémonie et ce défilé militaire
avec vous qui avez assisté justement
plusieurs fois à ceux à ce défilé on a
vu de nombreux vétérans autour de 2 la
dîmière poutine les vétérans bien sûr
ils sont excessivement important pour
pour cette cérémonie
oui alors la notion de vétérans a une
importance beaucoup plus grande en
russie que la notion d' anciens
combattants en france cela dit ne
serait-ce que démographiquement ses
vétérans de la deuxième
au mondial la grande guerre patriotique
sont en train de disparaître petit à
petit mais la notion de vétérans reste
un peu le symbole de l'union de la
nation russe face à l'envahisseur nazi
et même après leur disparition les
resteront un symbole très fort de
l'unité du pays
le président poutine a rappelé tout à
l'heure son vif intérêt pour la défense
des intérêts nationaux de la russie
est ce que justement la guerre a permis
de solidifier ce sentiment patriotique
et comment oui cette guerre à vrai dire
le 9 mai c'est la vraie fête nationale
russe
le 12 juin peu de ruse savait exactement
ce que c'est donc que c'est un moment
d'unité puisque c'est le moment où ce
câline d'ailleurs a fait appel même au
soutien de la tradition orthodoxe pour
lutter contre l'envahisseur et donc
c'est un moment d'unité nationale
absolument exceptionnel pour la russie
qui transcende les différences
politiques
les questions de de répression du temps
de staline est donc ce moment est sacrée
c'est vrai le mot n'est pas faible
vous parliez on parlait tout à l'heure
avec l'invité à précédent du discours de
vladimir poutine qui a dénoncé le retour
des idéologies xénophobes et russophobe
vous avez été ambassadeur de france en
russie est ce que l accusé nos phobies
la russophobie y est ce que c'est des
choses que vous avez vécu à l'époque où
c'est quelque chose de nouveau jeu je
prendrai pas un nom compte le mot bus
aux phobies qui est un qui est un
élément de gien de la tension actuelle
de là la discussion actuelle il est
frappant de voir que beaucoup de gens
qui sont extrêmement opposée à la russie
actuelle sont en même temps de le bon
connaisseur de la culture russe et la
langue russe
donc il y a une
utilisation de beaucoup de thèmes anti
russe dans le dans le jeu des tensions
actuelles sommes en fait dans une
nouveau type de guerre froide alors on
peut qualifier ça de russophobie mais il
est clair que de part et d'autre tous
les instruments de puissance 12 soft
power sont utilisés au moment où les
tensions montent
je le disais tout à l'heure vous avez
été ambassadeur de france en russie
qu'elle ait les qualités l'état des
relations diplomatiques à l'époque entre
la france et la russie est ce qu'elle se
sont détériorés ou améliorés à l'époque
elle était excellent mais il y avait
déjà quelques petits éléments de tension
au moment de la crise libyenne puis
ensuite au moment de la cuisse de
syrienne évidemment ça s'est accentué et
l'ukraine la crise ukrainienne a été
évidemment le déclenchement de d'une
véritable période de tensions cela dit
je ne dirais pas que les relations
actuelles soient à ce point dégradée que
le dialogue est plus fin que des idées
intéressantes ne soit mise sur la table
il est clair que les idées de dû par
exemple du président la république
française sur une nouvelle architecture
de sécurité de confiance en europe reste
valide donc ya des hauts et des bas nous
sommes dans une période de tension
incontestablement comme il y en a eu peu
depuis la la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
mais il ya sur la table un certain
nombre d'idées qui permettent de
redémarrer
j'ajouterai d'ailleurs que les
américains savent très bien qu'ils
doivent traiter avec la russie sur un
certain nombre de problèmes importants à
vous en avez parlé effectivement le
climat le terrorisme la question aussi
de l'évacuation de l'aghanistan variable
tout d'un toute une série de questions
qui doivent être traitées et donc j'ai
été très frappé par le fait que la
tension était à son comble
en ukraine il ya encore quelques
semaines et que c'est à la suite d'un
entretien entre le président mbaye danel
président poutine que la tension a
baissé donc de toutes façons les
éléments dialogues sont là et il faut
s'en réjouir
et personne ne conteste la nécessité de
se parler et essayer de régler ensemble
des problèmes on le sait jean de
gliniasty les les relations entre la
france et la russie sont sont
historiques justement à comment vous
êtes senti en tant que français qu'on
vous étiez ambassadeur en russie est ce
que justement vous vous sentiez que les
russes avaient envie d'entretenir cdd
bonnes relations avec avec la france
incontestablement
incontestablement il y a comme je
l'expliqué dans mon lit mais il ya une
espèce d'affinités qui est dû à
l'histoire la culture qui est dû aussi à
quelques héritages du général de gaulle
le nomme le régime en normandie niemen
qui reste très présent dans la mémoire
des russes un petit peu moins des
français parce que les français ont
souvent oublié leur histoire mais il ya
beaucoup d'éléments qui font que un
français se sent à l'aise en russie
incontestablement merci beaucoup aux
joueurs de guy nasty d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui sur l'antenne d'arte
france
je rappelle que vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur de france en russie merci
d'avoir commenter avec nous ce 76e
anniversaire de du jour de la victoire